good morning Hank it's Tuesday although
I'm filming this five days ago uh past
so distant I'm sure we're already
looking back on it with fondness anyway
today's video is like the Saturn 5
rocket it comes to you in three parts of
which the first part is by far the
longest part one other john green's not
to brag but over the last 40 years i've
become something of an expert in the
field of people named john green so
today I thought I would introduce you to
six of my favorite John Green's who
aren't me first John Green the Bigfoot
expert often called one of the Four
Horsemen of Sasquatch or John Green was
a small-town newspaper publisher until
the age of 45 when he left his career
behind to become a full-time Bigfoot
researcher John Green went on to write
several books arguing that large
human-like Apes roam the woods of North
America including year of the Sasquatch
which I actually own it's not bad fun
fact John Green once wrote into Mental
Floss magazine after I implied in an
article that Bigfoot didn't exist saying
that I had besmirched the good name of
John Green's everywhere secondly we have
professor John Green this John Green has
a great beard and just recently became
the interim president of the University
of Akron John Green is a professor of
political science who researches the
intersection between religion and
politics and American life so you know
that'll keep you busy then there's John
Green the artist who's maybe my favorite
John Green because he is the co-creator
of the amazing graphic novel series team
boat which is about a young man who has
all of the normal problems of being a
teenager but also occasionally turns
into a yacht John Green has said it's
the only comic that features the angst
of being a teen and the thrill of being
a boat John Green also does lots of art
for comics and video games you've
probably seen his work fourth we have
another bookish John Green sticker and
coloring book author John Green who has
been haunting me since 1998 when the
bookstore at my college began to sell
his sticker books I don't know much
about this John Green except that I
think he's into horses his books include
horses tattoo favorite horses stickers
little horses stained-glass coloring
book and both horses of the world and
wonderful world of horses which seems a
little redundant to me but I'm not here
to criticize that guy has published more
books about horses than I have published
books v John Green the designer this
British John Green makes excellent
furniture for instance he created the
cool embrace coffee table
which works two ways and then lastly we
have John green the cinematographer who
is technically a John Green even if he
does go by Jack John Green has often
been the director of photography for
movies directed by Clint Eastwood in
fact he was nominated for an Oscar for
Unforgiven but he's also been the
cinematographer for a huge range of
movies he's worked on good movies like
twister and speed - he's worked on great
movies like the net and he's worked on
all-time classics like Rookie of the
Year that's not a joke by the way Rookie
of the Year is a phenomenal movie don't
at me did that sound hip and young
slight side note that John Green has not
yet won an Oscar but John Green's as a
whole have in fact John Green the
composer won four Academy Awards and
also won Grammy meanwhile John Green the
TV producer has won three Emmys meaning
that we are only one Tony Award away
from a John Green II got based on my
singing and acting talents I don't think
I'm going to be the one to win it but
maybe that sticker book guys in the new
cats part to the tour Hank in September
and October you are going on the road in
support of your brilliant first novel
and absolutely remarkable thing which
comes out September 25th and is
available for pre-order now and I will
be joining you in New York Boston North
Canton Ohio Kansas City Chicago and
Indianapolis I am so excited for the
tour it is gonna be a blast ticket info
in the doobly-doo below
and lastly part three you are likely
familiar with the phrase don't forget to
be awesome but do you remember that our
catchphrase was in fact invented not by
us but by my friend Katie else in 2007
Katie is an acclaimed singer of Irish
music and her new album songs from
across the lake and sea has just come
out it is beautiful and haunting and
just wonderful there's a link to her
music in the doobly-doo below Hank I
will see you on Friday